>> Laura: CONGRATS ON THE BOOK
AND WE WILL PICK IT UP WHERE YOU
LEFT OFF.
I'M LAURA INGRAHAM AND THIS IS
THE INGRAHAM ANGLE FROM A BUSY
WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
WE WILL START RIGHT OFF WITH THE
LAWS OF THE LEFT, THAT'S THE
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."
HERE'S AN ANGLE RULE OF THUMB.
WHENEVER A DEMOCRAT AND
ELECTION-YEAR CLAIMS TO BE A
SENSIBLE MODERATE OR CLAIMS THAT
HE'S GOING TO CHALLENGE HIS
PARTY'S ORTHODOXY, LYING.
THE HEADLINE TODAY MADE ME HOWL.
MODERATE DEMOCRATS COME OUT
AGAINST BIDEN'S OUT OF TOUCH
SCHOOL LOAN FORGIVENESS
ACCORDING OHIO DEMOCRATS
TIM RYAN.
QUOTED DEL MICAH SAID THAT THE
DEBT CANCELLATION SINCE THE
WRONG MESSAGE TO OHIOANS WORKING
WITHOUT A DEGREE TO MAKE ENDS
MEET.
HE VOTED WITH PELOSI AND BIDEN
100% OF THE TIME THIS CONGRESS.
YEAH.
NOW BECAUSE HE'S RUNNING AGAINST
A REAL POPULACE AND J.D. VANCE,
HE'S TRYING TO MORPH INTO BEING
ONE HIMSELF.
IT IS ALL LIES.
THE TRUTH IS IF HE IS ELECTED,
JUST LIKE ALL THE OTHER PRETEND
MODERATES OUT THERE, ANOTHER
SURE VOTE FOR THE BIDEN AGENDA.
IF BIDEN STUTTERING DEMEANOR IS
SO BAD THESE DAYS THAT DEMOCRATS
WHO ARE UP FOR REELECTION ARE
SAYING THANKS, BUT NO THANKS TO
ANY PERSONAL APPEARANCES BY THE
LEADER OF THEIR OWN PARTY.
MARK KELLY IN ARIZONA COULD NOT
BRING HIMSELF TO TELL THE TRUTH
WHEN ASKED ABOUT BIDEN JOINING
HIM ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
>> I WELCOME ANYBODY TO COME TO
ARIZONA AND TRAVEL AROUND THE
STATE AT ANY TIME.
AS LONG AS I'M HERE, IF I'M NOT
UP IN WASHINGTON.
TALK ABOUT WHAT ARIZONA NEEDS.
>> Laura: OF COURSE, THAT'S A
LIE.
HE AND MOST EVERY OTHER DEMOCRAT
RUNNING IN A COMPETITIVE RACE
ONE BIDEN AND HIS 41.5% OF
APPROVAL RATING NOWHERE NEARBY.
SOMEHOW BIDEN HAS TURNED THE
CORNER AND JOE MOMENTUM?
HE'S GOT RENEWED FOCUS AND HAS
THE WIND AT HIS BACK.
REALLY?
>> THEY WANT A NATIONAL BAN AND
PASS THE LEGISLATIVE NATIONAL
BAN ON CONGRESS SPHERICAL THE
MAGA WINS CONTROL OF THE
CONGRESS, DOESN'T MATTER WHERE
YOU LIVE.
WOMAN WILL NOT HAVE THE CHOICE
TO RULE ANYWHERE.
WE WILL CODIFY ROE V. WADE.
>> Laura: THIS IS ALL BIDEN
AND THE DEMOCRATS TO RUN ON.
THEY HAVE NO PLAN TO TACKLE THE
FENTANYL SURGE AT THE BORDER OR
RAISE THE STANDARD OF LIVING.
BUT THEY HAVE A PLAN TO RAISE
THE ABORTIONS IN THE STATE.
SAVING YOU FROM THERE INFLATION
OR THE CARTELS, BUT FROM
REPUBLICANS IN PLACES LIKE
MISSISSIPPI AND OKLAHOMA WHO
WANT TO PROTECT THE UNBORN.
THEY CAN'T RUN ON THEIR REAL
AGENDA, BANNING GAS POWERED
CARS, BANNING BEEF, OPEN BORDERS
AND OF COURSE THE INDOCTRINATION
OF KIDS.
THEY'RE RUNNING ON THE ABORTION
LAW.
IT'S ALL POOR BETO HAS IN TEXAS.
>> TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT HER
OWN BODY, NO LONGER FREE TO
CHOOSE IF A PREGNANCY IS RIGHT
FOR US.
>> OR OUR FAMILIES.
>> WOMEN WILL DIE BECAUSE OF IT.
>> ALL BECAUSE OF GREG AT ITS
ABORTION LAW.
>> Laura: I WOULDN'T HAVE USED
THE HEARTBEAT BACKGROUNDS.
I THINK THAT I DIDN'T WORK.
THEY NEED SOMETHING, ANYTHING TO
GRAB ONTO TO AVOID BEING SWEPT
AWAY.
NO SURPRISE THEY WERE
ATTRIBUTING THEIR WIN AND ONE
SPECIAL ELECTION TO ABORTION AS
WELL.
SUDDENLY, THE RESULTS OF
NEW YORK'S 19TH DISTRICT WHERE
PAT RYAN BEAT MARK MOLINARO HAVE
OVERWHELMING SIGNIFICANCE.
HE MADE ABORTION RIGHTS A
CENTRAL FOCUS OF HIS CAMPAIGN.
THIS IS A BIG TEST FOR DEMOCRATS
WHO ARE HOPING THIS BECOMES A
DRIVING ISSUE AND MOBILIZES
VOTERS IN NOVEMBER.
>> THEY ARE SAYING ABORTION IS A
GOOD AND EFFECTIVE FOR THEM
ARGUMENT AGAINST THE ATTACKS ON
THE ECONOMY.
>> SUPREME COURT NUKING ABORTION
RIGHTS SHIFTED THE MOMENTUM TO
THE DEMOCRATS.
>> Laura: EITHER A LIAR
WISHFUL THINKING BECAUSE THE
TRUTH IS, THE OUTCOME HERE
TURNED ON A SINGLE COUNTY.
GUESS WHO WAS EXECUTIVE FOR THAT
COUNTY?
YEAH, THE COUNTY EXECUTIVE WAS
PAT RYAN.
IN FACT, DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN
POINTING TO THE FOUR SPECIAL
ELECTIONS THAT SWUNG THEIR WAY
SINCE THE DOBBS DECISION AS
PROOF POSITIVE THAT ABORTION
WILL LEAD THEM TO THE OUTLOOK
TWIRL PROMISED LAND.
BUT OF QUICK POLITICAL NOTES,
THE FOUR DISTRICTS HAVE
SOMETHING IN COMMON.
THE SUCCESSES HAVE BEEN HEALED
BY ENGAGEMENTS IN COLLEGE HEAVY
LOCATIONS.
POCKETS NOT ALL THAT
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE LARGER
FALL ELECTORATE.
NOT TO MENTION IN POLL AFTER
POLL, VOTERS SIGNALED THEIR
NUMBER ONE CONCERN IS THE
ECONOMY AND -- WAIT, WHERE DOES
ABORTION FALL?
AT THE EIGHTH MOST IMPORTANT
PRIORITY ABOUT TIME THINGS LIKE
EDUCATION, SAFETY, AND
SUPREME COURT APPOINTMENTS.
YOU'VE GOT TO HAND IT TO THE
DEMOCRATS BECAUSE AS REPUBLICANS
IN LEADERSHIP, THEY GRABBED
ABOUT THE QUALITY OF OUR
CANDIDATES, DEMOCRATS NO MATTER
HOW BAD THINGS LOOK AND DISMAL
THEY ARE POLITICALLY, THEY PUT
ON A HAPPY FACE.
>> WE ARE HAPPY.
IT FEELS GOOD.
IT FEELS GOOD TO LET THE SEASON
OF SHAME WHERE DEMOCRATS ARE SO
DISAPPOINTED AND FRUSTRATED WITH
WHAT'S GOING ON IN D.C. AND MADE
THE BY THE REPUBLICANS.
WE WENT FROM DISAPPOINTED TO
DETERMINE BECAUSE BIDEN IS
WINNING.
>> Laura: IF HE'S NOT LYING,
HE'S DELUSIONAL.
FOR BIDEN TO BE WINNING, HE
WOULD HAVE TO BE IMPROVING THE
LIVES OF THE PEOPLE HE IS
SUPPOSED TO BE SERVING.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
BUT HOW ARE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
FEELING ABOUT THINGS UNDER
BIDEN?
A MAJORITY IS SAYING AMERICA'S
BEST DAYS ARE BEHIND HER.
74% SAY THE COUNTRIES ON THE
WRONG TRACK.
IF THAT LEVEL OF PESSIMISM
QUALIFIES AS WINNING, I WOULD
HATE TO SEE WHAT LOSING LOOKS
LIKE UNDER BIDEN.
BUT WHEN POLLS BEGIN TO TIGHTEN
AS IS ALREADY HAPPENING IN
PENNSYLVANIA, I'M TELLING YOU,
DEMOCRATS PREPARE FOR THIS.
THEY'RE GOING TO LOOK EVEN MORE
DESPERATE AND BECOME EVEN MORE
DESPERATE.
BEYOND ABORTION AND THE
PROFESSED BELIEF THAT BIDEN'S
AGENDA IS POPULAR, THERE ARE
OTHER GO TO LYING IS THE SMEAR
OF MILLIONS OF THEIR FELLOW
AMERICANS.
THE RADICAL GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK
A KATHY HOCHUL DOESN'T WANT TO
DEBATE REPUBLICANS ON THE
ISSUES.
SHE ONLY WANTS TO DEMONIZE THEM.
>> WE ARE FIGHTING TO BRING
GOVERNMENT BACK TO THE PEOPLE
AND OUT OF THE HANDS OF
DICTATORS!
AND WE ARE HERE TO SAY THAT THE
ERA OF TRUMP AND ZELDA IN AN
MOLINARO, JUMP ON A BUS AND HEAD
ON THE FLOOR THOUGH.
YOU DON'T REPRESENT OUR VALUES
AND YOU ARE NOT NEW YORKERS.
>> Laura: NOT NEW YORKERS.
THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A MOMENT.
THIS FROM A WOMAN WHO TREATS
ILLEGALS AS FULL-FLEDGED
CITIZENS, BUT NOW TAXPAYING
RESIDENTS WHO DISAGREE WITH HER
POLITICALLY, THEY ACTUALLY DON'T
HAVE THE RIGHT TO LIVE IN THE
STATE.
SHE ACTUALLY BELIEVES THAT BY
THE WAY.
BUT LUCKILY, FOR THE G.O.P.
THERE'S A GOVERNOR WHO KNOWS HOW
TO FLIP THE SCRIPT ON THE TREE
DICTATORS.
>> WE PROTECTED PEOPLE'S
FREEDOMS, JOBS, BUSINESSES, MAKE
SURE KIDS COULD BE IN SCHOOLS
AND WE LIBERATED 22 MILLION
FLORIDIANS FROM LOCAL MANDATES
AND RESTRICTIONS.
WE PROTECTED THEM AGAINST FAX
MANDATES.
I THINK THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
DICTATORIAL ARE THE ONES THAT
WANT TO LOCK YOU DOWN.
>> Laura: BINGO.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO WERE FINE
WITH SHUTTERING SCHOOLS,
DEVASTATING EDUCATION, THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE, THEY ARE FINE WITH
FORCING POLICE AND NURSES OFF
THE JOB FOR IDIOTIC VACCINE
MANDATES ARE NOW CALLING
REPUBLICANS EXTREME.
>> VOTERS ARE EXCITED TO DEFEAT
THESE EXTREME REPUBLICANS WHO
ARE RUNNING FOR CONGRESS PERIODS
>> DO YOU FEEL LIKE THEY MISREAE
THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT CRIME AND
INFLATION.
>> THEY ARE MISREADING THE
LANDSCAPE AND DEMOCRATS ARE
DOING SOMETHING THAT WE DON'T
ALWAYS DO WELL WHICH IS WE ARE
DEFINED THE REPUBLICANS FOR THE
EXTREMISM.
>> Laura: ARE YOU GETTING THE
THEME HERE?
YOU KNOW WHAT'S EXTREME?
ROBBING CHILDREN, ESPECIALLY
DISADVANTAGED CHILDREN AND
MINORITIES OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GO TO SCHOOL ALL BECAUSE THEIR
PARENTS REFUSE TO GET THEM A
COVID SHOT THEY DON'T WANT AND
DON'T NEED.
THAT'S DICTATORIAL.
THIS IS PRECISELY WHAT THE
HEARTLESS MAYOR OF D.C. WHERE WE
ARE TONIGHT, MURIEL BOWSER IS
MANDATING.
NOT ONLY IS SHE BLOCKING ANY
STUDENTS WHO ARE UNVACCINATED
FROM ATTENDING SCHOOL, SHE WON'T
EVEN LET THEM LEARN VIRTUALLY
BECAUSE APPARENTLY YOU CAN GET
COVID FROM ZOOM.
FOR MORE THAN 40% OF
BLACK STUDENTS WERE
UNVACCINATED, NO EDUCATION FOR
YOU.
WANT TO TALK ABOUT JIM CROW?
THAT'S JIM CROW.
NOT JUST EXTREME, IT'S
VINDICTIVE AND I BET I BET SHE
HAS A HATE HAS NO HOME HERE
YARD SIGN IN FRONT OF HER
RESIDENCE TO BOOT.
REWARDING THE ELITES AND
FIGHTING TO KILL THE UNBORN AND
THE DEMONIZATION OF YOUR FELLOW
AMERICANS IS ONE HECK OF A
NATIONAL STRATEGY.
I SAY KEEP IT UP, DEMOCRAT